hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
today hopefully everyone is staying safe
staying healthy still under lockdown
quarantine social distancing and so
forth what we're offering you today is a
chance to be distracted little bit by
one of humanity's favorite things to be
distracted by lions and tigers and bears
oh my
mostly bears to be perfectly honest but
what we're going to be talking about are
carnivorous animals predators in the
wild and both how they hang out and how
they hang out with human beings how they
interact with us and how they should
interact with us so my guest is dr. ray
Wynne Grant who is a large carnivore
ecologist she studies again bears are
her favorite thing but also lions and
other large predators and tries to
figure out what their behavior is out
there in the in the wild how far they go
when they go for walking their mating
habits stuff like that as we will learn
as I learned you know this is not a
gorillas in the mist or Jane Goodall
hanging out with the chimpanzees kind of
situation basically you don't want to
hang out with the bears you don't want
to live with the Bears
Berner hair talk movies notwithstanding
you want to like touch the bears just
enough to put a collar on them trace
them see where they're going and then
let them do their thing but it's an
important thing because we want to be
able to live in harmony or as close as
we can come to it with the wildlife
around us and some of that wildlife is
dangerous some of that wildlife is big
and has claws and teeth and can hurt us
we want to protect that as well so we
need to understand it scientifically and
that's what we talking about today the
other thing to mention is that Ray is
going to appear on a TV special I'm
releasing this podcast Monday April 20th
Wednesday April 22 is of course Earth
Day and for mindscape fans it is also
the birthday of Ariel and Calvin my cats
but that is a coincidence that Ariel and
Caliban were born on Earth Day more
importantly National Geographic is
releasing a special to celebrate the
50th anniversary of Earth Day on April
22 it's a television event called born
wild the next generation and
ray will appear in there a whole bunch
of other people ray in fact works as a
fellow for the National Geographic
Society as well as being a visiting
visiting scientist at the American
Museum of Natural History so if you want
to see more because the pictures right
and the videos are always a hugely
compelling part of this kind of story
the audio is great their audio
conversation we had was very
entertaining but if you really want to
feel yourself there out in the wild with
the Bears and the Lions watch the TV
special and with that let's go
[Music]
raehwan gran welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you for having me I'm
happy to be here it's certainly a
fascinating two topic to talk about so I
think that the tentative title I came up
for this podcast episode is raehwan
grant on bears humans and other
predators and predators are sort of
weirdly alluring weirdly compelling
right like what is it that makes us so
interested in giant animals that can
easily kill us well you know I have a
lot of different theories on this but
they are so good for storytelling and
stories are such an important part of
human culture worldwide throughout
history and you know the danger element
again like it just feeds in so well two
stories and they're just they're
charismatic I mean not every carnivore
out there in the world is the most
charismatic animal but everything from
bears lions sharks I mean the the really
cool like carnivorous plants like
they're fascinating they just are so I
you know I can't blame people for being
captivated by them they hooked me it did
strike me while I was thinking about
this that our most popular domestic pets
come from carnivores from predators
right dogs and cats I mean there are
bunnies and hamsters but there's nothing
quite like a good dangerous cat to get
people really interested in fact you
know I was just watching an old episode
of cosmos with Neil deGrasse Tyson where
he details how you know we domesticated
wolves into dogs ages ago and why and
how it's such a mutually beneficial
relationship and it was just you know
just I think that kind of story never
gets old as well you know to really
understand that we took the vicious wild
animals I could have killed us and
turned them into man's best friend well
certainly you you count to someone who
is fascinated by these things I want to
get into the science of it but let me
just first ask about your research
process like you know there's lots of
pictures of you
they're in the field with bears with
lions and so forth are you so number one
what do you do number two is it mostly
your studying the the animals for their
own sakes or is it the interaction with
human beings that you care about
yeah great questions and you know I'm
always happy to talk about myself so I'm
a carnivore ecologist you know ecology
is a study of organisms and how they
interact with their environments
carnivores you know to oversimplify or
meat-eating organisms and I have a lot
of great images out there of me handling
some large carnivores because I do a lot
of fieldwork so there's a lot of ways to
do carnivore ecology I like to tell
people that you know wildlife ecologist
can be in the field and the lab in the
office you know there's all different
ways to do this work but I choose to
kind of do a hybrid of fieldwork and
field biology and then data analysis
which is you know bringing me back into
the office space yeah and my primary
goals at this moment and since I started
my career to look at patterns of
movement and behavior and so usually
when I'm out there you know trapping
let's these bears for an example you
know trapping bears and handling them
it's so that I can attach a GPS collar
to these animals so I do not just you
know go out into the wilderness and find
bears and cuddle them for fun although I
can't deny that it it can be fun really
fun there it is extremely purposeful
right a very very very purposeful and
the only way to get a GPS unit on an
animal is to capture that animal and put
that collar on and so that's where most
of those images come from so there's a
lot of photos out there of me with bears
that are sleeping they have been sedated
so that I can do this work and that is
probably you know the last time that I
will come into physical contact with
that animal for a year or two until I
find them again to take the collar off
and then I probably don't interact with
them again
so it's really important for me to drive
home to you know a lot of folks out
there that that the best ecology is
non-invasive non-invasive mm-hmm you
know it's not a great idea to get
animals used to humans and habituated to
humans so really like sedating them for
a few moments getting these devices on
you know doing health checks
you know checkups especially with you
know juveniles or babies and then
getting out of there and getting that
data you know analyzing those patterns
and learning about the animal from as
far away from as possible is the best
method I mean there are other approaches
right I mean everyone knows about Jane
Goodall and you know living with
chimpanzees where it's almost more
anthropology
we're yearly trying to study their
behavior by interacting with them so
you've been it's very good you've been
very clear that you're in there to sort
of attach some data capturing device to
them and then let them live their
natural life and that's what you're
actually trying to study that's exactly
right and you know Jane Goodall is a
huge huge inspiration for me so in a lot
of ways I bow down to her and her early
work but again she wasn't going to every
chimpanzee population you know on the
continent of Africa and living with them
she was taking one to use as a case
study to understand their behavior so
that we don't have to go into the other
populations and do the same thing right
right so it's kind of like you know just
they're taking one for the team you know
because I'm habituated to humans so that
we can understand their biology their
ecology use that information to kind of
make scientific conclusions for the
whole species
ok so I really want to sort of put
myself in as much of the shoes or boots
of you when you're out there tracking
the Bears as I can I mean do you know
exactly where the bear is going to be
how do you sedate it that is one
question oh yeah I love talking about
this stuff so probably some of my worst
and most boring stories from the field
are about looking for bears because the
answer to your question is no we do not
know where they are going to be lots of
yeah um you know if we use black bears
as an example I think it's hilarious
when I tell people that I study black
bears almost everybody I tell has a
black fair story to tell me you know
they went camping they saw a bear you
know they grew up in Vermont and Bears
used to come into their backyards you
know whatever it is so many folks have a
bear story I have her actually struggle
to find bears when I need to follow them
I don't know if it's like bad luck if I
have a curse whatever it is in my entire
life I have never seen a bear on
accident oh my goodness even I've done
that ever ever never I mean I would I
would love it so so you know when I'm
looking for these extremely wild you
know backcountry animals a lot of the
time I am hiking camping in the
backcountry for sometimes weeks on end
setting traps you know and these are
baited traps okay to lure bears to the
trap so that they will be captured
I can tranquilize them put the collar on
and then release them so to be clear
when we're talking about baiting a trap
I'm baiting it with things like you know
a can of tuna fish mm-hmm something that
is like yummy smelling but also
appropriate bears eat a lot of fish so
it is you know very natural for them and
then these traps are typically what we
call barrel traps or culvert traps which
are are very large so they're you know
big enough to hold a couple of bears in
them it's almost like a big cage okay
where the bear walks into the trap the
food the baited food is at the back once
it uses its paw to take the food a door
closes on the opposite side and I check
that trap twice a day to make sure a
bear isn't in there for too long it is
contained in there so it gives me an
easy shot to kind of stick it with a jab
stick with the sedative okay so it's not
like a gun from distance you have to get
close enough to poke the bear literally
yes quite literally and you know not to
get it twisted we do have tranquilizer
guns those are typically used when a
bear is in a tree and I would say like
when a bear is
causing a problem right like if they
were having a human bear conflict issue
when a bear is you know in somebody's
backyard going through their trash and
then you know the authorities show up
and the bear goes up a tree that's when
we might have to shoot it with a
tranquilizer just so that we can get it
back down and take it and release it
back into the forest but when it comes
to me trapping bears for the purposes of
putting a collar on them and it's really
just like a syringe on the edge of a
long stick sometimes I can widdle that
stick together myself
yep and you just like you just poke the
bear in the shoulder it it is probably
about the same as getting a flu shot
unless you know possibly less painful in
about five or ten minutes they fall
asleep they're asleep for about an hour
I you know weigh them measure them take
their temperature I have to use rectal
thermometer as I always try to throw
that in there because people think it's
amusing you know check the bear for for
parasites right so for no parasites but
you also threw in there that you weigh
them that sounds like an extraordinary
bit of effort there yeah you know I'm
only able to weigh these bears if I'm
working with a team so certainly
sometimes when I'm doing this fieldwork
I'm alone or maybe with one other
assistant but if I'm ever lucky enough
to have a team with me which is about
half of the time we weigh the bear so
when it is sedated and out cold we have
a tarp we kind of all lift the you know
many hundreds of pound bears onto the
tarp and we'll have like a big stick so
we'll find some type of big you know log
or something nearby kind of rope the
tarp around the log we have a scale that
we bring with us okay it is all very
makeshift but we weigh the bear in terms
of kilograms right there in the
wilderness let me pause for a second to
talk about
grammerly grammerly is a digital writing
assistant that works across a wide
variety of platforms Gmail Google Docs
slack and so forth and I think of it not
just as a spell checker or grammar
checker but as an editor as another set
of eyes that can read your writing and
tell
you how to improve it it's not just
saying what words are spelled in which
ways but suggesting interesting
vocabulary conciseness the power and
precision of your language so it's
always useful no matter how good your
writing is to get a second opinion and
that's what Graham really does without
actually asking any human beings it
works for you works you can communicate
with clarity and confidence on every
platform so if you want to move beyond
just saying your words to actually
making a statement with clear flawless
text that really has an impact go to
Graham early calm slash mindscape to get
20% off grammerly premium that's 20% off
grammarly premium at grammarly comm
slash mindscape gr a ma r ly dot com
slash mindscape so how are we when the
bear is in the trap is it sad is it
Angry are these bears used to this kind
of nonsense or is it like an angry bear
that you had to deal with yeah they're
certainly not used to it so it's very
unnatural one of the things that I love
about bears is that they don't have any
natural predators right in their
environments right they're they're top
of the food chain
they're apex predators themselves so I
find that they are not super afraid
necessarily of being in a trap you know
they just Bears don't have a lot of fear
ice but they will get you know they will
get aggravated because they don't want
to be in there especially once the food
is gone they want to like keep it moving
so it's really important just you know
to be humane to make sure that the bear
doesn't have too much of a stress
response to make sure that we are not
keeping them in there for more than a
couple of hours
you know I will also say big large
carnivores do a lot of resting so it is
not uncommon to have a bear go into a
trap get the food realize it can't get
out and have it just lay down for a bit
and you know kind of just take a rest in
the shade yeah that part has been
preserved in the domesticated cat I can
I can assure you
and so then you put the collar on and
it's a GPS system is that editors are
more complicated at Brad is involved no
it's a GPS collar so you know kind of
the same GPS level you might have in our
smartphones it's a small device that
hangs off of the collar it is very light
many of them are kind of large in size
but that does not equate to a
heavyweight yeah okay so it's just this
like lightly collar that goes on the
bear and the GPS sends a signal to a
satellite about in outer space and the
satellite sends signal to my computer
that lets me know the longitude and
latitude of the bear every couple of
hours and so that is that data gets
stored in a database and updated every
few hours and I have way more data than
I would ever need of you know where this
pair is going and looking over the
course of a year or best-case scenario
for two years we're able to really
establish the home range of the animal
and understand where it where it goes
and where it spends its time so you're
not tempted to put a little camera on
there little webcam on the collar I wish
we could get that far I wish we had that
type of opportunities but we really
don't we do a lot of trail cameras I
will say so I'll you know now that I am
associated with National Geographic I've
been introduced to all of these cool
photographers who often accompanied by
ologists into the field and they set
these great camera traps and they really
position them I mean it's amazing the
type of images that they get so you know
maybe there's a carcass that they expect
a wolf or a bear mountain lion to come
back to at some point and they'll
position this camera trap you know right
there at the carcass and get these
amazing images I use camera traps
absolutely all the time but when I'm
using them it's just to keep an eye on
my bear trap and that is because from
time to time I will set a trap and
actually have non bear animals go in
steal the food and go back out without
being trapped so I put camera traps out
just to see what's going on and why I
keep striking out and
spares are this is North America you're
mostly doing this yeah I do my work in
North America there's you know there's
eight different bear species around the
world over four continents
I study North American bears at the
moment so black bears and brown bears
and I'm hoping sometime soon some polar
bears okay but of course you know brown
bears are also in parts of Europe and
Asia and so you know a lot of the
conclusions and the ecological
information that we're getting from them
is useful in other parts of the world
and so what is it that we're actually
learning from these GPS studies I mean
clearly their range but is it more
behavioral is it more ecological yeah
it's both it's both so I'd like to do a
lot of comparisons and compare the
movement of bears that live and what
we'll call the backcountry so areas very
very far from human presence and compare
that to the movement of bears that live
in and around areas of high human
activity and we're finding you know some
things that might seem obvious to people
that backcountry bears you know we'll
have a much larger home range so you
know a lot of people will call that
territory size bears are cool they're
solitary animals so you're not gonna
find like a mama bear and a Papa Bear
hanging out together despite what
children's stories might tell us they're
by themselves and so they are also
territorial and so they like to
establish own territory so we'll see
like really really big home ranges for
bears that have that kind of space but
for you know for lack of a better word
urban bears I don't want people to take
that term too far because they're not
you know in the cities but for bears
that kind of live on the edge of the
human wildland interface we're finding
you know much more condensed home ranges
much more overlap especially in areas
where there are a you know an abundance
of food resources I also love using GPS
collars to look at where female bear's
den in the winter one of the coolest
things about North American bears I
think is that they hibernate and that is
awesome and you know figuring out where
they choose
to make their den is really interesting
there's some patterns that we see there
you know sometimes we see female bears
choosing to den closer to areas of human
activity and male bears Denning further
from human activity you know it raises a
lot of questions are females doing that
because the males have picked the the
best habitat and they have to go for a
second best habitat or is there
something about being nearer to people
that is actually a better place for
females to Den especially when they're
giving birth to Cubs you know a lot of
unanswered questions there but it to me
it's fascinating I mean I have plenty of
colleagues at Cal Tech who live in
Pasadena or Altadena and get bears
showing up to their swimming pools in
their backyards all the time so we are
we are at the bare human interface right
around here I can you guys sure are and
so it's interesting so when the bears
hibernate they do it solo they're not
they're not with a pal that's right yes
so you know again I like to often go
back to children's stories because
they're so sweet they always have these
like very pleasant bear families you
know and like bear communities all
hanging out and that is just so not
realistic
yeah bears are by themselves so like one
bear you know in in a me you know a
large part of the forest again they are
you know they are not close together
even when hibernating in dens so the
only time you're gonna have more than
one bear in a den is if you have a
female who has given birth and has Cubs
with her okay
something that I think is awesome that I
think everyone should think is awesome
is that females begin hibernation while
pregnant and actually give birth in the
den so in the ecology community we
basically estimate that every bear in
North America that's ever been born was
born in January that is just around the
time we all give him like a January 1st
January 15th birth date estimate that's
around the time that females give birth
in the den and then they give birth to
these teeny tiny little little bears I
mean black bear cubs what full at birth
can be about a pound
polar bear cubs at birth can be about a
pound and a half they're really really
small and they're kind of hairless and
blind and they just you know a couple of
them come out they nurse on their mother
for you know three four or five months
until it's safe to come out of the den
and by that time they're big and they're
strong and they're able to take on the
world
how big is a litter so a litter is
typically two to three for black bears
two to three four for brown bears as
well but they can be they could be big I
mean we usually don't see four more but
depending on the region two or three is
typical it's a little interesting to me
that they don't hang out in families
because since human beings do there's
this there's this inevitable temptation
to say things like well of course
mothers and fathers stick with their
children because they want to protect
their genetic line and you know preserve
it and so forth but then every such
generalization has a million counter
examples in the animal kingdom I mean
why don't mail Papa bears want to
protect their kids is there an
explanation for that kind of thing
you know we don't necessarily have an
explanation for it but it is in line
with solitary wildlife species so you
know the social animals and if we stick
with carnivores the social carnivores do
that right so wolves will create a pack
and they will you know the wolf dad will
take his wolf daughter off and teach her
out a hunt and always protect her and
they're like a very strong family unit
we see that with lion prides right so
you know a male lion you know at the top
of its harem will have all these
different females but we'll make sure
that no one's really going anywhere but
with you know with bears with mountain
lions with other solitary predators
we're really just seeing very very
different behavior they're kind of all
for one one for all you know a male bear
will mate with a female and probably
never see her again and never see his
offspring but is there some theoretical
understanding of what makes a species
social or not in that sense not
necessarily that I'm aware of at least
it's it's really the kind of this like
pack animal mentality and I think it
also has a lot to do with
they eat right like how they eat and how
they feed so if you look at bears I mean
they're so they're so fortunate that
they although they're carnivores they
are highly omnivorous right so their
diet they have a lot of dietary
plasticity is how we say it in ecology
so they do great eating fish you know
taking down deer in parts of the country
where I study bears we see them you know
eating wild horses the fonds of wild
horses I mean a lot of highly
carnivorous kind of predatory behavior
but they also do just as well eating
fruit and eating root vegetables and
nuts and seeds and berries and all that
kind of thing and because of that
they're kind of less dependent on each
other or on a group to you know to find
food resources and survive
you know mountain lions are obligate
carnivores they do a lot of hunting they
have to kind of catch their prey away
once they make a kill but they seem to
do pretty well being independent I would
love to kind of dig into more of the
theory of why some are and some aren't
but at this point you know bears just do
their own thing it's it it's one of the
things I love about them because I love
my alone time I consider myself a
solitary predator yeah like a an
introvert in a lot of ways I just really
like you know like having my own space
and I can relate to them a lot well I
mean this is it raises up a whole nother
set of questions that I was interested
in asking you about I mean why are there
carnivores at all predators at all in
the sense that a carnivore you know
something that eat eats other animals
relies on a whole huge ecosystem more or
less operating pretty well right because
those animals have to eat plants and
those plants have to exist whereas if
you just eat the plants directly maybe
things are a little bit more flexible
for you is it is it just a matter of
efficiency I know there's of course far
fewer predators carnivores than there
are herbivores but but they are there
and just about every ecosystem right
pretty much yeah and we see a lot of
issues when carnivores are removed from
different ecosystems
so they are important and I love that
you were able to acknowledge that we
don't need as many carnivores you know
in a space and we do herbivores and you
know composters and all the others but
they play a big role I love using bears
as an example again they are really
incredible
seed dispersers you know so we depend on
bats we depend on you know other types
of animals herbivores for a seed
dispersing but bears do a great job of
that but they also distribute vital
nutrients that they get from eating
animals so if we take you know those
brown bears up in Alaska that you know
just go crazy eating salmon during the
salmon run when they poop all throughout
the forest they're distributing vital
nitrogen all throughout the forest that
comes from eating those fish and
digesting those bones that allows the
forest to regenerate and keep growing so
the plant community is in a lot of ways
dependent on carnivores eating meat and
getting those types of nutrients
especially nitrogen and distributing it
pretty far and wide so that makes sense
in terms of the benefit that they get
what is the benefit to the carnivore of
being a carnivore the benefit to the
carnivore being a carnivore well I you
know what I think is cool and again I am
NOT any type of nutritionist but you
know protein goes a long way right so we
know that herbivores for example really
have to spend so much time grazing so
much time eating you know many of them
don't hibernate they have to make sure
that you know they're able to access
resources all year-round and it's kind
of a constant behavior right like
they're very very driven by being able
to you know to eat however many tons of
you know vegetation per day that they
need to survive whereas carnivores if
they get a good high-protein meal they
don't have to do that again for maybe a
day or two days so they're actually are
able to spend more time mating spend
more time you know finding new
territories spending spend more time you
know pooping and dispersing nutrients
throughout the forest it's really really
great for them to be able to take that
protein let it you know sate their
appetite and then do all the other
things that animals need to do and
sleeping yeah there's a lot of sleeping
that gets done and so much sleeping see
can't you see why I love them so much
it's like eating sleeping resting
exploring that's right and how do
carnivores get along with each other I
mean I read somewhere when thinking
about this episode that carnivores don't
eat other carnivores but do they compete
with other carnivores generally
different species of carnivores so you
bring up a question you bring up a
question that has been answered in some
ways but really depends on region and
the way that that different environments
may change over time or might be
changing in response to to human
activity so for the most part the other
not eating each other right so we don't
typically find carnivores eating each
other if I were to just oversimplify
it's because they don't want to expend
too much energy if a mountain lion
wanted to eat a bear it would have to
fight so so hard and nobody has time for
that they're a little bit lazy yep and
so it's way easier to like find a nest
of eggs to find a sick or very young or
weak herbivore to take down then like
pick a fight with another big strong
creature so that's pretty much why they
don't do it but you know it's not
completely unheard of for a very very
hungry carnivore to come across a
carcass of another one and maybe take a
few bites I mean that's not totally
unheard of because survival is also
important and remind me of the other
part of your question before I get too
far oh sorry I've already forgotten it
but I had an answer for it so I'm
getting a little frustrated but um no
I'm just well you know you know why you
know why there are you know do
carnivores sort of carve out sort of
domains of influence do they like say
okay you can get this
species like if there are wolves and
bears in the same ecosystem if they
don't attack each other do they
at least compete for similar resources
or is there an unspoken agreement
between them right and so that's where
we find a lot of complementarity
complement complementarity in these
ecosystems so I think it's just so
beautiful how nature often just kind of
works together it's like a puzzle right
and everyone kind of has their own fit
in the puzzle for the most part again
things are going to be widely different
if there is a change and the
availability of resources for one
carnivore one herbivore then things will
really get messed up and pretty skewed
and that's where we see you know some
really interesting things happening in
ecology I'll give you an example from my
study area in the Western Great Basin so
kind of a area where Nevada meets
California and the Sierras where we have
seen an increase in the black bear
population over the last 20-30 years a
very rapid increase in the black bear
population and a much slower increase in
the mountain lion population so the
mountain lion population has remained
pretty much stable you know increasing
but not as not as fast of a rate as
black bears and mountain lions typically
you know they are hunting deer they are
hunting you know elk they're they're
getting all of those herbivores and
we've seen as we've gotten more and more
black bears that they've actually
started to push mountain lions off of
their kills so when a mountain lion
kills something and kind of stashes it
away in a tree we're seeing black a
black bear we know one at a time kind of
come in and steal that carcass from the
mountain lion whereas typically they
wouldn't do that right so we're actually
seeing you know when we have collared
bear and a collared mountain lion if we
look at our map we're actually seeing
them interacting in space and time
actually kind of having a faceoff over
these kills whereas normally bears would
just kind of like take their fish take
their eggs you know eat all the juniper
berries that are
you know take up all their root
vegetables and so this is this is a
typical behavior from what we understand
about you know predator to predator
ecology and behavior and it's really
really fascinating so a lot of us are
questioning is it because the climate is
changing are there fewer vegetation
options for bears are there you know
more people in this part of Nevada and
California so that it's actually
restricting bears from going to places
where they would normally get their food
you know really what is it about what's
changing in the environment and creating
this kind of non perfect you know I
talked about the perfect puzzle that
carnivores make and we're seeing some
some disruption to that is there some
relationship between being a carnivore
and intelligence in a species do you
need to be a little bit quicker on the
ball to survive in this kind of
environment you know I don't want to
make too many generalizations because
you know if we were to talk about what
we consider some of the most intelligent
animals on the planet I think the top
view would be herbivores you know we
could think of a lot of like big whale
species that are non carnivorous we
could think about elephants there before
is we could think about you know
mountain gorillas you know they might
eat some insects but they're primarily
herbivorous but at the same time you
know that that predatory nature and the
ability to kind of understand like
opportunity like fear versus opportunity
risk versus reward is really unique to
you know apex predators like carnivores
and so there's there's I would argue a
different kind of intelligence that is
inherent in them and maybe sharks are an
example of a successful predator that
might not be that smart there you go
yeah yeah there you go I mean I I always
have trouble talking about it and I'm
will not being smart because I feel like
it's kind of disrespectful you know
we're animals too and yeah we're we're
brilliant but exactly so sharks you know
are fairly impulse driven and make a lot
of mistakes so that would be a good
example
and you meant but you alluded to the
idea that the populations are growing in
the United States for black bears for
mountain lions is that because we're
getting better at conservation yeah I
mean I love as a as a you know ecologist
as a conservation scientist I love to
talk about conservation success stories
because we're often plagued with what's
not working yeah you know we can talk
about carnivores on the brink of
extinction around the world all day long
I mean look at Tigers look at lions look
at sharks like we were saying but in the
United States there's been a lot of
conservation attention to carnivores to
wolves right I mean as controversial as
they can be
you know wolves grizzly bears black
bears polar bears mountain lions we've
done a really good job of giving them
attention you know putting some policies
and legislation in order to protect
their habitats and for many of these
species it has worked so if you went
back 50 60 years there were very few
black bears in a lot of spaces and
they've been restored to a lot of
ecosystems in in 2016 at the end of the
Obama administration he was able to take
the Florida I'm sorry
the Louisiana black bear off of the
endangered species list and so that
leaves no subspecies of black bears on
the endangered species list anymore
which is tremendous think of another
carnivore think of the bald eagle right
like back in the 90s we were plagued
with this information about how you know
critically endangered bald eagles were
you know their eggshells were too thin
and they weren't able to reproduce
successfully and now bald eagles are
soaring all over the place I mean you
can go to parts of New York City and
possibly stop spot an eagle it's really
really incredible and we've had a lot of
success what is the actual policy that
is most helpful here is it just don't
kill them or stay out of their territory
or something else yeah you know it
depends typical science responds it it
depends on the region it depends on the
dynamics of the area it depends on the
species so definitely the Endangered
Species Act
and the endangered species list has been
tremendously important right so that's a
huge piece of legislation that often and
I'm oversimplifying but it'll often say
okay
anywhere where this species is found is
protected area it also means you can't
hunt this species for the most part
right if it's on the endangered species
list it can't be hunted and that is a
huge way it's probably sounds really
obvious but it's a really great way to
protect species I mean many of these
species on the list have become you know
critically endangered because of over
hunting but also habitat destruction so
if there's a forest that we want to turn
into a ski resort but there's some type
of endangered species that lives in that
area we're not going to be able to do as
much development or sometimes any
development in those areas but also
there's a lot of kind of trade-offs for
for people and the economy that need to
happen so if I take the Louisiana black
bear as an example down south the
government actually started paying
agricultural workers so farm owners to
not farm on their land and to allow the
forest to regenerate in those areas okay
for as long as the Louisiana black bear
was listed and it worked so again these
people weren't you know losing money
losing their livelihoods they were
actually getting paid as if they were
farming actively they were also you know
just letting they weren't doing active
restoration of the forests but they were
just letting their land do whatever it
does naturally leaving bears alone not
hunting them and they were able to
rebound I did a wonderful podcast a
while ago now with Joe walleston who is
a conservationist and he actually had a
weirdly optimistic take that as human
beings move into more and more dense
urban environments it'll become easier
and easier to actually preserve large
amounts of natural habitats for for a
wildlife and for different kind of
species he so he puts it in the language
of if we get past the bottleneck where
we're killing off species too quickly we
can imagine a future equilibrium where
we live in harmony with
do you think that's a realistic kind of
prospect I absolutely do and you know I
I like talking about it in a kind of
different way because I fell into
conservation biology and wildlife
ecology as an urban dwelling person I've
always lived in a big city I was born in
big cities I never recreative for fun
until it became part of my career and so
often people ask me like oh gosh how can
you live in New York City how can you
live in Washington DC and and I'm so
happy to be able to give the response
like well it's better for the
environment in a lot of ways yes so
urbanization you know has been you know
there's been some metrics developed to
suggest that the more urbanized we
become as a human society around the
globe the more wild area is able to
flourish and so it's a great idea
there's what I what I find problematic
is the way many conservationists and I'm
not mentioning your your guest on the
show but the way a lot of conservation
is kind of will gloss over the the
social implications for it right and a
lot of the kind of ethics about people
who may choose to live murali or
especially you know particularly tribal
lifestyles and and not want to be urban
so we don't want to necessarily suggest
people like that are a problem or a part
of the problem sure but if you know if
people opt into living an urban
lifestyle if an urban lifestyle is it is
rewarding for them like there's enough
job opportunity you know like we can
kind of solve poverty in cities it
offers so much opportunity for
conservation to work and and fairly
quickly you know just kind of like
getting off the land pretty quickly
shows that nature is able to respond
really really well and it could be what
saves the planet have you seen the
pictures of you know like the coyote
walking down the streets of Chicago
everyone is now down in lockdown
wildlife moves in pretty good yeah and
the the bears in Yosemite right like
that's a protected area in itself but
you somebody's especially this time of
year is used to having a lot of visitors
and bears are now coming out of
hibernation you know in parts of the
mountains too no visitors you know so
mother bears are able to kind of just be
free with their cubs and just use all
different parts of the forest that they
weren't able to before all the animals
are so happy right now
maybe not the tiger in the Bronx Zoo who
got Corona but all the other ones one of
the things that Joe Wilson did mention
is that historically almost all of the
great conservationists and
environmentalists came from cities yeah
those are the ones who sort of feel the
danger of the landscape around them
disappearing more intently I guess
something like that but no interesting I
did not know that and that lets me feel
way better about yeah not just you but
but there's this a big set of questions
about how regardless of whether we're in
cities or in the country how human
beings should interact with these great
animals right with whether it's lions or
bears or whatever should we in your in
your estimation should we sort of try to
rope them off keep them apart and you
know leave them alone or will there
always be these kind of overlap zones
where there's the occasional little
black bear taking a dip in someone's
pool in their backyard yeah this is a
complex question and I have strong
opinions about it and and I really you
know I guess I will start by saying that
it's so important to me that humans
acknowledge where we are and what land
we're on right so even if we are
preaching that we should you know move
towards more urbanization you know
understanding that like right now I'm in
Washington DC like understanding that
before this was a big city this was a
place with bears and lions and wolves
and you know a whole wildlife community
so when we do see a lot of these animals
kind of showing back up as as their
population sizes increase as we see
them like in the you know exurban spaces
and the sub urban spaces on the edges of
towns and cities to really understand
that that is naturally and historically
where they were meant to be the other
thing I'll say is that as long as we are
responsible I think humans have a huge
responsibility towards promoting human
wildlife coexistence mm-hmm
bears are a great example to use when we
talk about this because humans attract
bears to where we are if we weren't
barbecuing on our backyards if we
weren't you know throwing out trash if
we weren't leaving our dog food you know
in the dish on the porch bears that can
smell you know scents from over a mile
away wouldn't necessarily be interested
in coming on to you know the edge of
town to dig in your trash so the more
responsible people can be at at
eliminating attractants to wildlife
again it could be bears but it could
also be raccoons it could be you know
the Coyotes it could be the deer right
like if you plant a yummy garden you
can't necessarily be super upset that
you know some herbivore wants to come
and eat it right like you were creating
human food resources in a place that is
easily accessible to an animal so the
more responsible we can be the less
selfish we can be I think
the easier we'll find coexistence and I
think the easier we'll find living with
increased population sizes of wild
animals you know I often give talks
about you know human bear coexistence
and the places where I do my research
and I'll have people come up to me
afterwards and say you know oh you know
I I have a bear-proof garbage can I make
sure to be really responsible in this
way in this way but you know I still
have bears in my backyard and I'll say
things like you know well do you you
know do you have a bird feeder you know
do you have a do you have a what do they
call it like a fountain a little
gurgling water fountain in your backyard
you know things like that are still you
know resources that Bears need and it's
especially as we're adding in the
complexity of climate change for example
where that's skewing you know when
resources are available and the
predictive nature of that you know these
animals are going to go for the easiest
option especially in places that are
their ancestral homes yeah the other
thing I'll say is that you know it is
everybody's goal myself included to have
a vacation home somewhere so as urban as
we want to be you know when we are
building our vacation homes and our
vacation spaces in these beautiful areas
with gorgeous mountains and beautiful
forests you know we're we're encroaching
on wildlife habitat and so that has to
come with the acknowledgement that you
know bears might be there too well and
also the knowledge meant that they are
legitimately dangerous right you know we
want them to survive and flourish etc
and if we are going to have a world
where there are overlapping regions then
do we need to do at least the people who
frequent those overlapping regions need
to be better educated in how to get
along on a day to day basis or literally
what you do when you stumble across one
while hiking yeah absolutely I mean
safety is super super important and
again it speaks to coexistence I love I
just I can't say enough good things
about bears I love using them as an
example again when we talk about safety
because there are actually a a really
non aggressive species especially if we
talk about black bears right like black
bears don't have a whole bunch of fear
but they also don't want any problems
you know a lot of carnivore is like we
were saying before they don't want to
fight they are not interested in
expending their energy on fighting
they'd much rather rest relax get a meal
hang out and so it really takes a lot of
triggers for a black bear for a brown
bear for you know for a mountain lion
for a wolf to attack you you really have
to be provoking them so just making sure
that you can make your presence known if
you come into contact with a bear you
back off you look you know you look away
so you don't make eye contact with the
animal because that can be seen as
aggressive okay you look at its feet you
look above its head so you're not making
that eye contact you slowly back off if
you if you are hiking I always recommend
bear spray bear spray is just a great
deterrent because it's you know it's
pepper spray essentially and it is
extremely irritating to the eyes your
your eyes included and so it is just a
great way to kind of create a barrier
between you and the animal so the animal
says okay I don't want any kinds of
problems here and you're able to just
you know calmly make your escape I mean
I always see these rules or instructions
for what you see when you encounter
bears and there they seem completely
different if it's a brown bear or black
bear or grizzly bear and there's zero
chance I'm gonna remember what to do
depending on what kind of bear it is
they the advice you just gave is pretty
universal you think it's pretty
universal and again like what you're
saying is that there is really different
advice for whether you are encountering
a bear or whether you are being attacked
by a bear so if you're being attacked by
a bear there are like kind of different
sets of advice or what to do if it's a
black bear you're encouraged to fight it
off if it is a grizzly bear you're
encouraged to like ball yourself into a
little ball and play dead until it is
done messing with you if it's a polar
bear I'm sorry you might not make it but
again if you are you know on a hike and
you see you know thirty feet ahead of
you is a bear that is when you stop in
your tracks you know make yourself look
either really big or really small back
away don't make eye contact and just
slowly leave make sure that you position
yourself as not a threat to the animal
not interested in the animal okay okay
very good that's good to know
i I did have a couple of extra little
science questions just about what we've
learned from your studies of the Bears I
mean we can basically study them in
space and in time it seems to me that
they're pretty sparsely distributed
right like there's not like
said Big Bear cities huh is there some
knowledge of how they find each other
you know dating is hard enough in the
big city for human beings with all the
sort of apps like is there a procedure
by which bears sort of do socialized on
those rare occasions yeah so in terms of
mating they smell each other you know so
female Bears make sure to mark their
scent male Bears make sure to follow
that scent and so they actually just you
know they have such an incredible sense
of smell that they smell each other from
really really far away meet up at the
right times and then you know say
goodbye forever okay and the only times
that we might see bears congregate in
the same area is if there is some common
resource that they don't need to fight
over so again like if you just think of
those classic you know videos you might
see on youtube or on you know National
Geographic of bears you know at a river
with spawning salmon you know and you'll
see a number of bears all together
they're not fighting over you know one
salmon there is so many to go around
that they will congregate at the same
time each day get their salmon and then
again be in very separate places for the
rest of the day that's right and I mean
we are here among other things to
mention that there is a National
Geographic special coming out this week
as the same week that the this podcast
is going to be released called
born wild to the next generation and
you'll be in it and people can see
exactly those images that you say of the
Bears hunting and hanging out and so
forth yeah and the great thing about
this show that's coming out and and I
can't wait to see what my colleagues
were up to the other explorers all over
the world who are going to be featured
in this show is that you know as much as
I work with sedated bears would I have
my hands on them
we're actually we filmed this in the
winter when we were doing a bear den
survey so I'm actually working with
newborn cubs and so we never give any
kind of you know any kind of drugs to
pubs when they're that little so we're
actually seeing awake bear is active
adorable cutie pie little baby animals
who have never seen the light of day
before we take them out of the den for
you know ten minutes
it's just enough time for us to weigh
them measure them you know sex them and
check their overall health before we put
them back with mom so it's an amazing
glimpse into kind of the secret life of
bears but also the secret life of bear
biologists and I can't are the Bears
so antisocial that it's not even worth
sort of studying their social networks
like our do bears have you know friends
and enemies and nemesis and frenemies
and stuff like that or do they just like
just keep away from the other bears yeah
they really I mean they're antisocial
and people hate it when I say that I
think it brings a lot of disappointment
you know again because we're kind of we
as humans are socialized to believe that
they are just like friendly and sweet
and you know always out together and
they're the protagonists of all of our
stories but really they don't you know
if they pass by a fox and the forest
they're not stopping to say hi but you
have also this is a good segue because
you've also done research in Africa on
big cats right Lions in particular or
yes yeah African lions and their
sociability strategies are completely
different which you know still I still
am waiting for the grand unified theory
of this but meanwhile let's you know
collect all the data and figure out how
in what way they are different and their
sociability yeah they are so so
different the studies that I always did
were very similar to how I was studying
bears so I was looking less at their
behavior and more at their movement
patterns so in my studies of African
lions I was again you know capturing
them putting a GPS collar on you know
one or two members of the pride and
really looking at how they're using the
landscape and what landscapes they're
using so if you think of you know a huge
African savannah
a lot of us might want to think that
that Lions are using every square inch
of that savanna but it's not true
there's actually parts of the savanna
that they completely avoid parts that
they use all the time and parts that
they just pass through so my work has
always been to just understand their
movement which helps us understand their
ecology and especially how we can
protect the most important areas for
those lions and if any kind of landscape
development is needed
for the human economy where we can best
fit that in in order to still protect
lion habitat yeah I mean I understand
why for conservation and ecology
purposes you want to know where they
spend their time but as the physicist I
want to know why they spend their time
in certain places you know I'm sure I'm
asking a lot of questions to which the
answer is just not known but like do we
understand why lions enjoy hanging out
in certain regions and just pass right
by others or avoid them entirely yeah I
mean we have baseline understandings and
again every region is different right so
there is I actually have a colleague who
is right now hypothesizing that there's
something about the soil types of
different parts of the savanna versus
other parts that might actually be
driving some of this habitat selection
preference and you know it's a big
question but you know that's the cool
thing about science the cool thing about
ecologists is that one question leads us
to another to another you know if I were
to be super general of course it's all
about food resources and water resources
you know the dry parts of the savanna
where there's no fresh water they're
gonna avoid those areas because they're
you know there's no herbivores going to
the watering holes and so they have to
go farther to look for food but it can
be more complex and it can also be
seasonal right so in certain seasons
lines over here in certain seasons lines
seem to be more all over the place you
know it really depends and we see that
lion movement and behavior might be
different in you know parts of South
Africa versus parts of East Africa
versus parts of Central Africa so that's
what I love about ecology is that we
have some kind of basic baseline
information that we can generalize to an
entire species but if you take you know
one population one pride you can
actually really dig in and see some some
differences that then make you question
everything well I keep coming back to
this social network question because you
just mentioned differences and even
though there are you studied lions but
there's other kinds of big cats and as
far as I my me core understanding goes
there social networks are just entirely
different right there are also very
antisocial cats as well as very social
ones oh yes absolutely so you know if we
if we hop to a different continent we
can look at Tigers right that are not in
these big prize we could hop to North
America look at mountain lions which are
solitary or you could even stay in
Africa where we're talking about African
lions and look at leopards right which
are on their own unless we're talking
about a female so so it's I think it's
just truly truly fascinating and and I
have never studied big cats other than
lions so I am NOT as much of an expert
but it is so fascinating to me how you
know these these animal species that
could have so much in common and a lot
of ways do actually behave so so
differently from each other yeah there's
a lot of contingency and randomness in
the evolutionary history that means that
you know some things are selected for
because they work or don't but a lot of
things just might be accidents there
might not be a reason why right yeah you
know that's one of the things that I
love so much about learning about
evolution and how it relates to ecology
is that so much is random right I mean
when I was a student I actually studied
what we call the neutral theory of
evolution which is you know just
basically questioning low what if all
this is just happening at complete
random and it's a great way to question
some of the patterns or things that we
think are patterns that we see in the
nature community you know like why is
this species social in this species this
and you know we think we can identify
some reasons but it could have just over
as in randomly and it just works for now
and we'll see how it continues in the
future but again to me that is you know
a way to emphasize why we need
conservation because we want to answer
some of these questions in the future we
can't do it if we don't have these
animals is there so just a lot last
question what do you see as your hope
for future and goal your equilibrium
like how should we imagine living in
harmony maybe too much but at least you
know in a mutually mutually beneficial
equilibrium with the big predators that
we're talking about today yeah you know
I when I think about what I see as the
future
of conservation I often kind of surprise
people because I bring in a lot of human
social issues so I truly think that
conservation cannot be successful
wildlife conservation cannot be
successful unless we eliminate poverty
from human societies so so much of what
we see as a threat to conservation
especially at local and regional scales
is due in part to you know the
prevalence of poverty in different
places so when I think of a future of
conservation I think about you know
equity for communities I think about
economic infrastructure that can help
alleviate or hopefully eliminate poverty
so that we can really have humans in a
good enough place so that we can you
know have the best thinkers and the best
minds and the best strategies available
to protect nature and allow nature to
thrive that's a good thing I think that
we should all shoot for Raylan grant
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast thank you for having
me Shawn this was fun
[Music]
you
[Music]